cj watson is a las vegas native he
played in the nba for 10 years and he
just released
his third children's book welcome back
to the show cj how you doing buddy
doing good how are you thanks for having
me well first off we've got cj's big
dream
cj's big project and now cj's big moment
what is the theme of your children's
books uh well the last one the third one
that just
came out cj's big moment uh it's about
bullying and uh just
showing kids how to handle bullying in a
positive manner i want to promote
we don't want to promote violence we
want to prove positivity and uh just
kind of handling things in a positive
manner so are the books based on your
life we're talking about cj here
are the books based on your childhood
were you bullied as a kid
i wasn't bullying him but i had a couple
of bullied uh stories i can tell but
this is definitely a true story
all these stories are definitely things
that happened in my life and i just want
to tell my story through books
now speaking of children you you're a
new father so so congratulations
how has becoming a dad changed your
world uh
for the third time i think it's uh i
think i'm getting better the third time
around um
uh just staying up late uh changing
diapers uh now
back to bottles and diapers and things
of that nature so it's just uh it's
always fun just to bring another
another human to this world and uh just
trying to make our uh the best that we
can
no now talking about children's books uh
growing up did did you have a favorite
that maybe your parents read to you
every night or was that go-to kids book
that you read and if so what was it
uh it's probably like the dr seuss books
i love those uh all those books i think
my favorite was like probably like
uh green eggs and ham just always loved
those themes of the books uh they kind
of
made me smile as a kid made me be
creative maybe think and wonder and
and kind of dream so i think reading as
a kid helped me be an author
i love it because is that that's what
you're doing for kids now making them
think and
dream and my last question for you
you've been on the show many times i
always wanted to ask you this about your
mba career
you played for the golden state warriors
the bulls the nets the pacers and
orlando magic
do you have a favorite team uh i think
i would say the bulls is my favorite
team i would say all of them actually
because they all gave me a shot
and uh but i would say the first team
the orders they gave me my first
legitimate shot in the nba to
kind of make that dream come true kind
of hold my basketball skills and they
kind of developed me as a player so i
would say the warriors is my favorite
team because i gave you my first start
cj you're a las vegas native and we love
you so much thanks for joining the show
we get your books on amazon thank you so
much my friend
thank you thanks for having me
appreciate it you can get all of cj
watson's books including his latest cj's
big moment on amazon